Ich schrei mir eben stellen.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte mich kurz vorstellen. Ich heiße Seema Karakashli.
Ich bin auf diese...
Und sagen Sie nochmal Ihren Namen bitte. T. Karakashli.
Karakashli.
Ich glaube jetzt...
Ja, so ungefähr hab ich es.
Okay.
Und ich bin auf diese Station als Assistenz erst in Tethi.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, klar. Ja.
Okay.
Kurz zum Ablauf möchte ich zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten abfragen,
dann Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden am Ende ein paar Informationen über Ihren...
Ihren Familien.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Bruno Schlüter.
Bruno?
Und wie heißen Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam bestellen?
Ja, der Vorname ist B-R-U-N-O.
Und der Familienname ist Schlüter.
S-C-H-L-U-T-E-R.
Okay, also männliche Namen.
Ja, genau.
Okay. Herr Schlüter.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Jetzt muss ich tatsächlich gerade rechnen, ich habe das versorgen.
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt, das heißt ich bin 76 geboren.
Also bin ich...
Ja, ich bin am 6.07.76 geboren.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Rechenbeder gemacht, ja.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 Meter und wiege...
So genau nehme ich das nicht, 86, 87, 88 Kilo.
So genau zeigt meine Waage, glaube ich, gar nicht an.
Ich wiege mich auch nicht oft.
Okay. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also ich habe so merkwürdige Bauchschmerzen.
Und ja, das ist eigentlich schon lange, aber das wird jetzt irgendwie immer mehr.
Und ich war bei meinem Hausarzt, der hat mir nur gesagt, ich soll weniger Alkohol trinken.
Und dann bin ich da nicht wieder hingegangen.
Aber jetzt irgendwie geht es mir insgesamt nicht so gut.
Also ich bin gar nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Ich arbeite im Straßenbau und da muss man ja schon ein bisschen anpacken.
Und ja, das fühlt mir jetzt irgendwie doch schwer.
Und ja, und diese Schmerzen irgendwie so im Bauch, das ist ja auch nicht so schön.
Okay, aber ich habe nicht verstanden. Was machen Sie von Berufich?
Ich bin Straßenbauer.
Ich bin also im Baugesäge.
Okay. Wo liegen diese Schmerzen am stärksten vor?
Also unterbauch oder oberbauch?
Ja, eher weiter oben und ziemlich in der Mitte, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Also wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz,
oder wobei null von null bis zähn, wobei null keinen Schmerz und zähn,
sehr starker Schmerz ist.
Ach, wo in der Mitte, würde ich sagen.
Also fünf, sechs.
Okay.
Sind diese Schmerzen eher dumpfartige oder krampfartige,
ziehende, brennende?
Ach, wie kann man das beschreiben?
Also es drückt so, es drückt eigentlich, ja.
Ja, glaube ich, so dumpfdrückend, ja.
Also haben diese Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen oder langsam?
Ich würde sagen, das hat langsam angefangen, sonst wäre ich glaube ich auch schneller gekommen.
Ich bin jetzt nur gekommen, weil es eigentlich immer schlechter wird,
weil ich mich so schlecht fühle.
Aber die Schmerzen habe ich ja schon eine Weile.
Und am Anfang waren die nicht so schlimm.
Und die sind jetzt also eigentlich von Woche zu Woche ein bisschen schlechter geworden,
wobei wenn ich morgens aufwache, habe ich das Gefühl, ach, das tut richtig doll weh.
Und ja, dann im Laufe des Tages, ja, dann arbeite ich halt und so,
dann vergesse ich das so ein bisschen, dann wird es auch wieder ein bisschen besser.
Aber wie gesagt, die Arbeit fällt mir schwer jetzt.
Erdmann.
Okay.
Wir sind jetzt, wie gesagt, im Laufe der Gespräche.
Okay, strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Strahlen?
Was meinen Sie, dass das irgendwo anders hin auch weh tut?
Ne, das ist nur hier oben so im Bauch.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, dass diese Schmerzen lindert oder verschlechtert?
Haben Sie bemeint?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher?
Nein, das kenne ich gar nicht, nein.
Okay.
Also haben Sie dagegen eine Schmerzmitteil eingenommen?
Nee.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie momentan diese Schmerzen?
Ja, die sind ja immer so ein bisschen da und ja,
heute sind sie auch da, ja.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen ertragen oder soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerz mitteilen?
Nein, ich renne ja schon drei Monate mit rum.
Also da kommt jetzt auch eine Stunde nicht an.
Okay.
Haben Sie Übelkeit erbrochen?
Ja, einmal habe ich mich auch übergeben.
Ja, und zurzeit fühle ich mich auch wirklich schlecht.
Also da ist mir schon mal, der ist mir schon mal richtig übel.
Und ja, also einmal, einmal habe ich mich auch übergeben,
aber vielleicht habe ich da auch irgendwie ein bisschen viel getrunken.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, wenn ich versuche,
wenn ich die Treppe hoch gehe,
dass ich dann wirklich so ein bisschen Probleme mit der Luft habe.
Ja.
Okay, und dann habe ich noch Probleme.
Ich habe das kenn ich von früher gar nicht.
Also, dass ich ordentlich Blähungen habe.
Also immer so Luft im Darm.
Das ist manchmal ganz peinlich.
Sind diese Schmerzen nahrungsabhängig oder lageabhängig?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Also ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Sortbilden oder müssen Sie öfter abstussen?
Nein, also wie gesagt, Übelkeit ja und einmal auch erbrechen,
aber sodass das dauernd irgendwie so sotbrennen ist,
das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Leiten Sie an Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Fieber. Also nachts schwitzt sich manchmal.
Das ist mir wohl aufgefallen.
Also müssen Sie Ihre Nachtweiche wechseln?
Ja, manchmal ist es schon so,
dass ich dann etwas Frisches anziehen muss,
weil ich so nachts schwitzt bin.
Aber haben Sie kein Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugehend um?
Ja, ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Wie gesagt, ich wiege mich ja nicht so gründlich,
aber was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass meine Hosen mir alle irgendwie ein bisschen knapp sind.
Das knifft alles, ja?
Also die Hosen sind zu eng.
Ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen dicker geworden.
Aber haben Sie nicht gemessen?
Nein, ich merke das nur,
dass ich ein bisschen dicker geworden bin.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, also Durchfall habe ich schon auch hin und wieder mal.
Aber ja, das hat mein Jahr mal.
Und dann geht es wieder weg.
Aber ja, doch manchmal habe ich Durchfall.
Und wie gesagt, diese Luft im Bauch,
dass ich so Blähungen habe.
Also wie sieht das Ihren Stuhl aus?
Genau gucke ich mir das nicht an.
Das kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen.
Aber ja, okay.
Kein Blutung?
Blut ist mir da nicht aufgefallen.
Das hätte ich wohl gesehen.
Wie sieht auch Ihren Erbrochen aus?
Ja, das ist das, was ich vorher gegessen habe.
Ja, es sind Reste.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchlaufen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Nein, Entschuldigung.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an Herzklopfen, Herzrasen, Husten.
Also Herzrasen, wo Sie das jetzt so sagen?
Ja, also ich merke das zum Beispiel.
Wenn ich die Treppe hochlaufen und nicht so gut Luft kriege,
dann habe ich auch das Gefühl,
dass das Herz schneller klopft.
Und auch manchmal, wenn mir so ganz übel ist,
dann habe ich auch das Gefühl,
dass das Herz irgendwie ein bisschen mehr klopft.
Herr Schlüter, leiden Sie an krönliche Erkrankungen?
Ich bin ja eigentlich gesund, ich bin ja noch nicht so alt.
Und ich habe ja, ja, arbeite ich ja auch immer.
Also der Arzt hat mir etwas gesagt,
deswegen bin ich da auch nicht mehr hingegangen.
Der hat mir gesagt, ich soll weniger trinken.
Die Leberwerte wären nicht so gut.
Und dann bin ich da einfach nicht mehr hingegangen.
Also wann war Ihre letzte Leberwerte konzentriert?
Ich rote das schon ein paar Jahre her.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als junger Mann hatte ich meinen Bruch nach dem Unfall,
mit dem Unterschenkel.
Und das ist operativ versorgt worden.
Also ist diese Operation komplikationlos verlassen?
Ja, das kann ich ja wieder laufen.
Nehmen Sie Beibedarf oder regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, Aspirin nehme ich mal oder Ibuprofen,
wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
aber jetzt mit dem Bauch, da würde ich eigentlich keine Medikamente nehmen.
Und dann hat mir mein Arzt eigentlich das noch verschrieben.
Ja, regelmäßig nehme ich das auch nicht,
aber wenn ich dran denke, nehme ich Omelprazul.
Okay, aber nehmen Sie das nicht regelmäßig?
Ja, ich bin da nicht so genau.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ja, ich vertrache alles.
Ja, da gibt es keine Allergien.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, das ist so vollständig.
Also zur Corona-Impfung bin ich hingegangen.
Ja, sonst weiß ich nicht, sonst habe ich glaube ich alles, was man braucht.
Also sind Sie gebustet?
Ja, genau.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Ja, zum Frauenarzt eher nicht, ich bin ein Mann.
Ah, ich schuldigung.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, meine Mutter lebt nicht mehr,
warum lebe ich tatsächlich eben gucken.
Ah nee, umgekehrt nicht, also meine Entschuldigung.
Also mein Vater lebt nicht mehr, der ist Mitte 70 verstorben,
der hatte irgendwie eine Lebererkrankung.
Und meine Mutter, der geht gut,
die hat ein bisschen Bluthochdruck und die hat auch Zuckerkrankheit.
Aber ansonsten kommt die ganz gut zurecht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Ich bin geschieben.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die Kinder, die sind aber, ja, die sind bei meiner Frau beziehungsweise
sind jetzt auch schon so gut wie aus dem Haus.
Okay.
Aber leben Sie allein?
Ich lebe alleine.
Okay.
Sie arbeitet Straßenbauer?
Wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Möller.
Okay.
Lassen Sie uns über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen.
Okay, rauchen Sie?
Oh ja, ja, ja, klar.
20 Jahre rauche ich wohl schon.
Ich habe nicht so ganz früh angefangen, aber ich rauch ziemlich viel 30 Zigaretten am Tag.
30 Zigaretten, okay.
Haben Sie noch versucht, eure Aufrufe hören?
Nein, es war ein bisschen teuer, aber ich habe ja sonst nichts, wofür ich arbeite.
Ja, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie viel Alkohol trinken.
Also, was trinken Sie?
Ja, was nennen Sie so viel?
Also ein paar Flaschen Bier am Tag und Schnaps zum Runterspülen brauche ich dann auch Wohnmal.
Wobei in den letzten Tagen hat es nicht so gut geschmeckt, aber bei der Arbeit kriegt man halt auch nicht Durst.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie eingenommen?
Nein, also nur Schnaps und Zigaretten, das reicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine gelbliche Fahrveränderung an Ihren Haut oder an Ihren Augen bemerkt?
Ne, also das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Aber so genau gucke ich auch nicht ins Spiegel, so erfreulich ist das nicht.
Ja, Herr Schlüter.
Ich glaube, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ach, Sie haben ja mich so viele Sachen gefragt und ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen könnte.
Ja, was machen Sie denn jetzt mit mir?
Okay.
Um eine Abschiedszende Diagnose zu stellen, muss ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen und dann Blut abnehmen und dann Bauchultraschall veranlasen.
Ja, gegebenenfalls Computer-Tomografie veranlasen.
Was ist denn eine Computer-Tomografie?
Es ist eine bildgebende Verfahren mit Hilfe von Röntgen, also Strahlung.
Sie liegen auf einer Untersuchungsliege und mit Hilfe von Strahlung können wir Ihren Organe darstellen oder untersuchen.
Und ist das gefährlich?
Diese Untersuchung ist schmerzlos.
Brauchen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Wenn Sie Angst haben, bekommen Sie eine Beruhigungsmittel.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht notwendig.
Ja, gegebenenfalls natürlich.
Okay, gut.
Okay, ja.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Hat jemand Fragen zu diesen Patienten?
Ich habe keine Frage.
Das war sehr komplett und sprach nicht wirklich sehr, sehr gut, würde ich sagen.
Also, da gibt es überhaupt nichts dran zu bemängeln.
Ja, aber brauchen Sie noch einen Moment oder wollen Sie gleich weitermachen?
Ja, ich brauche ein paar Minuten.
Ja, ja, alles klar.
Vielen Dank.
Nächste Dienstag.
Okay.
Ja, hallo Frau Oberarsten.
Ich habe eine neue Patient aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen den Fall vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, danke schön.
Herr Bruno Schlütter ist 47-jährige Patient.
Er ist 1,80 Meter groß und 86 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns wegen seit 3 Monaten epigastrische Bauchschmerzen.
Er berichtet, dass diese Schmerzen zunehmend sei.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 auf einer Schmerzskala, 0 bis 10.
Diese Schmerzen sind druckende und dumpfende Charaktere.
Und die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Sie strahlen nirgendwo hin aus.
Sie klagte über Belastung Dispne und Blechung.
Also Flatulent.
Die Frage nach Zotbrellen, Aufstoßen, Cyklerus, Icterus wurden verneint.
Die Frage nach Vorhörigen, Ähnliches Beschwerden wurden verneint.
Er hat nicht viel Kilo zugenommen.
Er klagte über Neusea und Vomitus.
Er hatte nur 1-2 Mal Essengeschmack.
Er hat kein Blut im Stuhl bemerkt.
Er hat eine Leidung bei Belastung Tashi Cardi.
Er hat eine verschriebene Omeprausol.
Er ist ein Straßenbauer.
Er rauche seit 20 Jahren 30 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Er trinkt ein Flasche Bier und Schnaps am Tag.
Danke schön.